Waffle House is an American institution
and a great place when you're hungry but
honestly late now you can get a little
volatile someone finds a bacon strip
short in their All-Star special and
things can get out of hand that happened
in Austin Texas at a Waffle House about
a year ago someone caught it on video
pretty amazing here it is
[Music]
on fire so even by the standards of
Waffle House brawls this got a little
zany at one point someone threw a chair
at a Waffle House employee and here's
the amazing thing that employee
effortlessly batted the chair away like
Wonder Woman with her bulletproof
bracelets you're seeing that on your
screen right now so naturally we wanted
to speak to this cool-headed Waffle
House employee who was completely
unintimidated by throwing chairs online
she's known as Waffle House Wendy her
real name is Haley booth and we're
honored to have her join us tonight
Haley thank you so much for coming on
you were not intimidated and the tape
proves that at all when a lunatic Waffle
House Diner threw a chair at your head
how did you remain so calm
um I really don't know
um it was it kind of just all happened
so fast it was mainly just a pure Rush
of adrenaline and Instinct that just
kind of had me going
had anyone ever thrown a charity before
I mean
kids get Rowdy in middle school but not
like directly at me
yeah good well that I mean that speaks
well of the country you grew up in um
how did Waffle House I mean I'm watching
this and I'm thinking I don't think I've
seen an employee calmer Under Pressure
than you I assume you got some sort of
award and special bonus from
Waffle House corporate how big was your
bonus
um I actually didn't get any bonus of it
uh the only thing that I did get from
the fight was a write-up for breaking
the sugar Shaker
um so and you know telling them them
telling me you know hey
we're gonna write you up for the sugar
Shaker but you did a good job you know
protecting the store making sure that
you were all right
wait wait you were written up for
breaking a sugar Shaker when someone
threw a chair
did you point out that you were the
victim here
they watched the cameras
and then you saw the whole thing on the
company camera on yeah like the security
cameras and whatnot
huh so you were not
rewarded or awarded for your bravery
under pressure
yeah no sir
do you still work at Waffle House
uh no two months after the fight
um me and my relationship was getting a
little bit more serious so I moved out
of city and they had told me that I'm
always welcome back at that store and
you know well glad to have you back you
always have a place here and about six
months later when I went to apply at
another Waffle House in North Carolina I
had found out that I was blacklisted and
on the do not hire list
because someone threw a chair at you
um I honestly think it was more of a we
can't have you nobody can type thing
I don't think it had anything to do with
the fight
and I should have asked you this at the
beginning but my last question is why
did this fight start do you know
um all I know is that they were
extremely drunk or at least intoxicated
and it was a slow night I was the only
cook and there was about 30 40 people in
there that I had to cook for by myself
so it was it was moving slow so drunken
impatience creates a volatile situation
I hope they all went to prison I bet
they didn't
just I didn't want to press charges
um I felt that the situation had been
resolved and everyone could go on their
way
you're a nice person thanks for joining
us tonight we wanted to meet you I'm
Glad You Came Of course yeah
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight